Here is a simple example of creating threads with pthreads,
let's look at the main function first.
We see that in a loop we create pthread_create a number of times or, and
we create four threads where each of the threads executes the function hello.
All this function does is print Hello Thread, it doesn't take any arguments and
that's why we pass NULL as a argument to the pthread creation function.
We also pass NULL in the attributes field because we're okay with
just using the default pthread's behavior.
That also means that these threads will be joinable, so
then we have to, in a loop, join every single one of these threads.